ever since i'd say around the jimmy
carter administration
the democratic party has consciously
abandoned
the working class consciously undermine
unions with which they used to be very
closely tied
and instead gone for an alliance
a voter base based on the professional
class
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations
with fascinating people our brilliant
guest today is a u.s journalist
aaron mate welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me
it's great to have you listen uh a lot
of our viewers we were just talking
before won't know who you are but
we feel that you've got a very
interesting voice to add to the mix
tell everybody a little bit about who
you are how are you where you are what
has been the journey
that brings you here talking to us well
i'm a journalist i'm i'm a leftist
and i work for an outlet in the us
called the gray zone
and i also write for the nation magazine
and
my focus for the last few years has been
primarily this russiagate obsession in
the u.s and how russia was blamed for
basically
all of america's domestic problems
including the election of donald trump
and how i think that feeds into a very
dangerous dynamic of
encouraging a you know cold war
militarism between
the west and russia and also excusing
failed neoliberals for their own
failures among many other
bad uh outcomes and uh
that's take up a lot of my time but i
also cover generally
foreign policy and particularly the you
know how the us
undermines governments abroad that it
doesn't like
for reasons coming back to the fact that
these governments
stand in the way of u.s hegemony so
that's pretty much the focus of my work
and uh
that's you know you know i can go to my
long life story but i'll save that maybe
for later
yeah well so you basically would it be
fair to say you represent
the anti-imperialist left would that be
about right
certainly people would associate me with
that
i i try to avoid terms like that
personally just because i just think i
represent
factuality uh but
uh sure yeah in terms of if you want to
sign a category absolutely i'm
definitely a part
of the anti-imperial slave i don't
believe in the in the self
uh appointed right of strong states to
interfere
in the affairs of others um well we'll
probably get into more of that but the
first question i wanted to ask you
relates probably more to the media
landscape than anything else because
russia gate has obviously been a big
part of your work and the way it seems
to work nowadays if you oppose
uh essentially lies about uh
someone like donald trump which is what
we're talking about that automatically
means you're a huge fan of his
and you're secretly you know it's trump
or jason and all the rest of it
uh are you secretly trump or jason aaron
i am not secretly trump with jason no no
i'm not
no i uh i really when he won that was a
very dark
couple of weeks to process that and his
presidency i think was a disaster
for the us and for the world and i
really did not
want him to win re-election
the problem though is that i also don't
think that joe biden
and the part of the party the the
democrat of the democratic party that he
represents
were really a better
alternative except the fact that i just
think they're less worse so i'm not a
big fan of joe biden or
anything he does i just think that the
trump and the people around him
were so dangerous and part of the reason
why i opposed russiagate from the start
was not only because i thought it was
based on a lie
and a lot of deception and that there
was just
key pieces of evidence were missing on
all these core claims
but also because i thought it was
actually a big gift to trump because
if you're trump would you rather have
your opposition
focused on your policies like you know
this tax heist in which trump's tax cuts
transferred
a massive amount of wealth upwards to
the top one percent
or pulling out of the iran nuclear deal
or
pulling out of a bunch of arms control
accords with russia
or tearing up environmental treaties or
would you rather have them uh focused on
this crazy conspiracy theory that you're
really
a puppet of vladimir putin and there's
this secret conspiracy going on
and as soon as we find all the as soon
as we find out the smoking gun
your presidency will be over well if i'm
trump it's an easy choice i'd much
rather have my
opposition turning into crazy
conspiracy fanatics and that
unfortunately what the democratic party
was for pretty much the bulk of trump's
presidency
it was blue anon as i called it as i
call it we've heard of q anon
the democratic party was blue and on
literally every single day
liberals being bombarded with conspiracy
theories about trump and his associates
conspiring with russians and it was all
a scam
and we saw that when at the end of the
mueller investigation they came up with
nothing
and the only reason some people thought
they might have found something is
because there was more deception
and more disingenuous rhetoric to make
people think that there was something
there when really there was nothing i
think it was a disaster
for the opposition to trump in a
disaster for the world because
another impact of all this was to
encourage increased confrontation
between the u.s and russia which
i think for many reasons is a very bad
thing and
aaron why was it that they were so
focused on
russiagate when it comes to trump
because let's be fair if you
if you've got a target i mean if there's
a lot to criticize on the bloke
why is it that they were so focused on
russia
well let's start with how the democrats
lost in 2016.
so you have hillary clinton who is the
embodiment
of this neo-liberal warmongering
warmongering establishment hillary
clinton who supported the war on iraq
who supported the dirty war in syria who
supported the
destruction of libya who supported
so-called free trade policies that
decimated the u.s working class
so she comes along and she's the
candidate for the democratic party
she faces this clown in trump a
reality tv show host who is able to
convince people
because of his rhetoric on the campaign
trail that he is some kind of working
class champion who is going to take on
the establishment
and drain the swamp and enough people in
enough states
were so disgusted by the
clinton obama legacy that they were
willing to take a chance
on this clown trump who was saying
things like you know
i'm gonna bring back jobs and bring back
our factories and he also
was criticizing the foreign wars that
hillary clinton
had supported and that worked and i
think there are many people who
probably didn't believe trump but i
think they were so contemptuous
of what clinton represented that they
figured why not go with this guy
he's saying at least saying the right
things and it worked
so for democrats if they want to do
honest self-reflection on such a
humiliating defeat
to this clown then that means that they
have to reflect
on their actual positions which would
require them to come up with a genuine
anti-establishment alternative to trump
to challenge him on so instead of
trump's
fake populist anti-establishment
rhetoric for democrats to learn from
2016 and then challenge him to feed him
they would have to come up with a
genuine anti-establishment alternative
but the problem with that is that that
would mean undermining
their own power and privilege within the
failed system
that let trump become president and they
couldn't do that
so they had to come up with a bunch of
excuses for their defeat
and in a very classic dynamic find
external enemies to blame
and very early on that became russia so
russia was now at fault for trump russia
was the reason
that we had trump because russia
brainwashed
millions of americans with their
sophisticated social media posts
and their hacked emails and moreover
there was even a conspiracy between
trump and russia and that is how trump
got to the white house
not because of our failed policies so i
think that at its core explains it
and then you have a convergence of
factors and other privileged sectors
beyond the democratic party leadership
you have a media that gave trump
billions of dollars worth of free air
time
so they also don't want to do some some
honest self-reflection
and moreover if your focus is on
russia and you're blaming russian
oligarchs like oleg daraposka
for trump then that means you can avoid
scrutiny of
american oligarchs people like sheldon
adelson and robert mercer
and all the other billionaires who
preside over a rigged system
frustration with which trump was able to
exploit so
for a media that serves these same
powerful interests blaming this external
enemy
serves a very useful purpose and finally
you also have elements of the national
security state
who also tried to undermine trump that's
very obvious now
with all the false leaks that they put
out falsely suggesting that there was
evidence for a trump russia conspiracy
they didn't like trump not because they
don't like his racism
but because they didn't see him as a
suitable steward of the us
war machine he's a buffoon and he says
the wrong things
he's actually honest sometimes and when
he talks about what the us really does
around the world so for example
in syria when he kept us troops there he
said very openly
we're there to take the oil yeah barack
obama or joe biden would never say that
they'll say we're there to confront isis
or to
protect our strategic interests they
wouldn't be so blunt
like trump is to say yeah we're there
for the oil so that's not good when you
have a president who was being honest
and who was pulling the mask off of the
empire
and plus there's one very more there's
another very important factor here
trump on the campaign trail was
successful
in criticizing the foreign wars that the
national security state
survives on basically he was criticizing
the war in libya and the dirty war in
syria
and so that's not good when you see that
having appeal
amongst a large base of people so
ascribing all that to russian influence
was a good way to stigmatize it and a
good way to say that this is not how we
talk in the us this is all russian
influence
so it's bad and it has to be taken down
so i think all those factors
are what explain why we got four years
of russia gate madness you raise a lot
of really interesting issues there and
which we'll dig into
uh but we you obviously talk about the
2016 election if we move forward a
little bit
to the election that's just happened uh
first of all let me just a quick fire
question do you think
if there's no covid trump gets elected
again
i do think trump would have gotten
elected yes i think there would have
been or at least a much stronger chance
that trump would have gotten elected and
in fact
there's a new book by a couple of
reporters
jonathan allen and uh
annie parnes it's called lucky the book
is called lucky
and it's about joe biden's election and
it quotes one of his advisors
who says that coveted was the best thing
that ever happened
to biden so even from inside the biden
camp there's a recognition that if not
for kovid
uh trump would have been in a much
stronger position because look the
economy
at least on paper was doing pretty good
and again going back to russiagate
what had the democrats offered the
public for four years
insane russia conspiracy theories and
basically the fact that they're not
trump
so that was the sum of their opposition
pretty much was that we're not trump
oh and also russia is at fault for
everything that's going on in the u.s
including donald trump
so democrats had not offered voters very
much they hadn't really
put up a very robust opposition to
trump's actual policies
so i don't think democrats had given the
voters enough of a case
to win back the people they lost in
2016. and so i think it's very plausible
to speculate that if not for kovid
which trump handled so terribly that he
would have been in a much stronger
position
and aaron we after the the 2020 election
you know everybody was using the phrase
the adults are back in the room
the left's back in charge now you get a
little smile from you there
you see still haven't lost the old
comedic charm uh aaron
what is your opinion he's already
laughing about biden
what does biden represent to you
biden represents the same neoliberal
establishment of the democratic party
that lost to trump in 2016
that under obama presided over a massive
loss
of power at all levels of government
except for the white house
uh until 2016 when they also lost the
white house as well
and you know he supported every hawkish
foreign policy position over the course
of his career
for pretty much every everyone there are
some exceptions uh
he authored the infamous crime bill
which led to
a massive increase in imprisoning
people of color he has been a long time
friend of wall street especially
the credit card industry so biden to me
is just a
you know a figurehead for the same old
neoliberal elite
who didn't offer voters much
this year except the fact that he wasn't
trump and i think enough happened for
people to just get sick
of trump and how much of a clown he was
that that was enough to push
biden over the top but will that be
enough to hold on to power
on the domestic front you know he's not
been
terrible i think he's been better than
obama although that's not hard he
just passed this stimulus bill that will
cut child poverty in half it will
increase subsidies to parents with
children
it will expand medicaid those are all
good things at the same time
did he fight for a 15 minimum wage when
joe manchin blocked it no he didn't he
could have actually
pushed that through but he caved on that
so
he i think has learned some lessons from
obama's failure obama who i think was a
very tepid leader
but not that much and to really
make effective change you have to have a
movement of people behind you but
biden and his circle i don't think are
interested in that they just want to
work with the republicans that they can
and centrist democrats
and push through incremental reforms
that do a little bit but don't do that
much
that for example can't even get to the
level of giving people a livable wage
like 15
an hour and can't even give everybody
health care
which is just a global scandal that the
us the supposed
you know civilized country can't
guarantee health care to all of its
citizens
especially during a pandemic so do i
think biden
will be able to overcome the
[Music]
corruption and dysfunction of the
neoliberal wing that he represents to
win again in 2024 if he runs again i i'm
very not very confident of that
aaron it's really interesting having
this conversation because of all the
criticisms that have been made about
trump over the last
four years five years now we didn't
really hear
from the mainstream much of what you're
saying you criticized this tax policy
which there's a lot to criticize i very
very rarely did we on certainly on this
side of the pond hear any of that
and many of the other things you're
talking about and at the core of what
you're saying
is you talk about biden being a
neo-liberal
and you call yourself a leftist can you
explain to people who may be
unfamiliar with the technical terms what
you're talking about when you say him
and clinton represent neoliberalism
and what you mean when you talk about
being a leftist and i get a sense of
that that is
largely economic in your case but break
that down for us
yeah well basically ever since i'd say
around the jimmy carter administration
the democratic party has consciously
abandoned
the working class consciously undermined
unions
with which they used to be very closely
tied and instead
gone for an alliance
a voter base based on the professional
class
um and relying on the donations of wall
street which became
infinitely more power with the uh in the
1980s with the deregulation
uh policies overseen by ronald reagan
and bill clinton when he ran
pretty much ran with similar policies
economically as
reagan so it's pretty much instead of a
democratic party that is
you know champions workers it's one that
is tied instead to
massive uh uh corporations
and wall street and sees deregulation
and unfettered finance as sort of the
vehicles for growth
allowing for worker protections
and worker rights to be consistently
undermined that's been the direction of
the democratic party
since pretty much the carter
administration and if you look at
how what clinton did with nafta the
so-called free trade deal which moved
a whole bunch of jobs abroad it
completely decimated u.s manufacturing
deregulating the telecommunications
industry which led to a
greater consolidation of corporations
owning the media
um and then his foreign policy of also
continued hawkishness which is not that
much different than the republicans
you see basically a a one-party system
in the u.s
between involving the democrats and the
republicans they only differ slightly on
social issues so
where democrats differ is culturally
they're they're more evolved so
they believe eventually it took them a
long time actually it only took them
it actually took them to the obama
administration to even recognize gay
marriage
but basically they start recognizing
cultural and social rights a bit earlier
than the republicans do that's basically
the essential difference between
uh democrats and republicans and that's
what
defines a neoliberal is pretty much the
same economic policies and foreign
policies of republicans
but on cultural social issues like gay
marriage
and the separation of church and state
they're you know they come along with a
more
i think evolved position a bit earlier
and what about you
when you talk about you being a leftist
what is it that you want to see
the us government doing well at home i'd
like to see the us government provide
for its people's basic needs
so for example healthcare it's just a
scandal that
this country supposedly the wealthiest
in the world does not guarantee health
care for
all its citizens unlike every other
industrialized country
and abroad i like to see the us stop
terrorizing the world
which it has done for
over a century especially since coming
out
incredibly powerful after the second
world war so today
you know the fact that under trump you
have an attempt to overthrow the
government of venezuela
and you have an attempt to overthrow the
government of syria and over the
government
of iran and to illustrate just how
bipartisan this
is biden comes into office and he's
essentially continuing all of trump's
policies
he's keeping the sanctions in place on
iran syria and venezuela
which deprive those governments of
much needed revenue uh and are helping
to weaken
the states of those countries and most
importantly are impacting as they're
designed the civ
the civilian populations of these
countries which have a harder time
importing medicine which plunge a lot
more people into poverty
and all because the us doesn't want
their governments in power so
you know because i oppose all these
things i you know you can call me a
leftist and i've just always
identified with any effort to challenge
illegitimate power and any imperial
power that is interfering
in the affairs of other countries while
meanwhile depriving its own citizens
of their basic needs hey francis
do you like martians well i'll work with
one don't i
would you like to have an immersive
experience with a martian
are you going to get me drunk on the
vodka near my
looks like last time you wish no
there's this great new immersive
experience in london based on jeff
wayne's
the war of the world i've heard about
this the audience reviews have been
incredible it was rated one of the top
20 things to do in london
at night and 98 of guests recommend it
the experience features a cast of 17
characters
12 live actors plus a mix of holograms
projections
and vr of west end stars you feel all
your senses fired as you cool
slide and weave your way through 22 000
feet of immersive action including 24
extraordinary scenes and having to
escape 300 foot
martian machines and the evacuation of
london
it is fully compliant with covert
regulations and they're offering
up to 10 pounds of standard weekday
tickets with our promo code
which is of course trigger all you need
to do to take advantage of this
fantastic
offer is go to the war of the worlds
immersive.com
that's the war of the worlds
immersive.com
and experience a world where we're being
invaded by martians
which is still better than being in
lockdown follow the link in the
description
and i'll see you there and aaron
don't you think that the democratic
party
lost how can i put this any legitimacy
with the fiasco with what happened with
bernie sanders
and it looked like he won the democratic
democratic candidate
and then it it then disappeared into the
ether and hillary was elected despite
the fact that most people didn't even
want her as a candidate
well look i i have no
uh affection at all for hillary clinton
and i certainly think that what they did
to bernie sanders was a complete
scandal and yeah they don't have any
legitimacy in my eyes but you know look
she did still get more votes than him
and you can argue that
he would have won if not for the dnc
rigging
the primary against them it's possible
but we don't know that for sure we don't
and look bernie won bernie ran again in
2020 and he didn't win
and uh it's just a fact that
while certainly of course there is uh
bias
and even efforts to sabotage bernie
sanders by the dnc
and in fact there are probably people in
the dnc would rather have trump win
reelection than bernie sanders if he had
been the candidate
it's still a fact that it's very hard to
mobilize leftist
candidates in this country and and left
ascendant because there's so much
against it and
it's just quite possible that we haven't
arrived there yet with bernie sanders
that even
without the rigging of him that it just
might not have happened so yes
to answer your question shortly of
course they were biased against them of
course they tried to undermine him and
it speaks to the obstacles that left us
face
in trying to build power the same thing
we saw in the uk with jeremy corbyn
who came very close to winning uh
the entire election in 2017 i believe
yeah
we saw from leaked emails that members
of his own party sabotaged him
and worked against him and then after
that we saw a coordinated effort to
sabotage him with these fake allegations
of
anti-semitism and cornering him
on brexit which i think all of which was
designed to undermine him because
neoliberals i think possibly hate
progressives more
than they hate the right wing uh because
they have a lot more in common with the
right wing than they do with
progressives like jeremy corbyn and
bernie sanders
i mean i would say to you just from a uk
perspective um
jeremy corbyn was not the best candidate
too that he had some
issues in terms of likeability with the
general public but let's not get into
that actually
well look he he came closer than any
other labor leader that i can think of
to winning the prime minister's office
in 2017 it was a few thousand votes shy
he did uh he did at that point but his
policy on brexit completely ruined uh
ruined his uh the perception of him with
the general public
right but what i'm arguing there it's my
understanding look i haven't followed as
closely maybe as you have but it's my
understanding that he was boxed in
by the elite of his own party which did
not want to accept
the result of brexit so jeremy corbyn
tried to basically and i think he made a
mistake
from from my reading of it although
again it's limited and trying to appease
both the results trying to trying to
recognize both the result but also
appease
the elite of his own party by saying
that you know we're going to hold
a new vote on whether to accept the
terms of brexit right that's how it went
down
which i think was a mistake i think he
should have said no there was a vote we
accept the outcome but
he faced a huge amount of pressure from
within his own party
and i think that pressure was
consciously aimed at undermining him of
putting him
in an impossible position and i think it
did play a factor in him ultimately
losing
well what i would say to you aaron i
think you're right in your analysis what
i would add is you were right earlier
when you talked about the change in the
democratic party in the united states
the same thing happened to the labour
party where they ceased to be the
representative of the working class
in this country and so the reason jeremy
corbyn was so torn between
supporting uh the vote that had happened
which by the way he probably voted to
leave in
uh and uh you know the other people in
this party
it was because the bulk of the party was
now the middle class
sort of metropolitan elite uh and so
it wasn't so much those people
undermining him as the fact that his
party wasn't really the party that it
used to be
uh but anyway let's not let's not get
get stuck into that if
if anything is worth pushing back on is
probably the conversation about foreign
policy with you because
some people might argue uh you know i'm
from russia i'm no fan of the russian
regime some people might argue well
the united states is the beacon of light
in the world it's the one place that's
created democracy surely the united
states has a
as not only a right but a duty to to
offer a bulwark against
you know vladimir putin's dictatorship
the chinese communist party
etc what would you say to that
imperial states always believe that they
have the right
and the duty to uh impose
their system on foreign countries and
it's always cloaked
in beneficent language like we're doing
this for the good of the world the nazis
said the same thing
but what's the evidence for it the us
has uh
repeatedly overthrown governments around
the world including democratically
elected governments uh for the crime of
either standing in the way of u.s
hegemony
or being a socialist government that
wants to use your resources for
your own people so you can find a
million examples iran in 1953
elected a nationalist government that
wanted to use iran's oil
for its own people while still actually
sharing
with the western oil interests that were
in iran but that wasn't enough for
the us and britain who overthrew it and
that set off
actually the ongoing um
conflict between the us and iran that
continues today and has caused a lot of
suffering for the people
of iran you can go to nicaragua in the
1980s where the u.s waged a terror war
to undermine the sandinista movement
which
tried to use the the country's you know
meager resources for its own people
instead of the traditional elite and you
have that pattern repeated
across central america where the us has
consistently waged dirty wars
to overthrow socialist governments and
undermine socialist movements it's still
happening today in venezuela
where you had a government that came in
after years of rule by the country's you
know light-skinned elite
ugo chavez in in the late 1990s coming
in presides over a massive
increase in quality of life for his
people because for the first time
venezuela's oil reserves are being spent
on its population not just going to a
tiny
sector of the elite and the u.s starting
with a coup in 2002
has tried to repeatedly undermine that
continuing today
under the trump biden sanctions that are
destroying venezuela's economy so
for anyone who thinks that the us is a
beacon of light onto the world and has
brought democracy
to the world i ask you to show me where
and in response i can show you
countless examples where they've done
the exact opposite
i mean the the question with venezuela
and
hands up i'm half venezuelan is slightly
more complex than that
with uh with chavez with you know the
rampant uh corruption the suppression
of human rights his targeting of
journalists many of whom are my family
have had to literally flee for their
lives so
i accept your point that whether the u.s
should be involved in that
but when it comes to venezuela itself
it's slightly more complex in that would
you not agree aaron
i refuse to discuss venezuela without
acknowledging
the context of the u.s waging a
20-year campaign to to overthrow its
government
and of course i'm not denying that there
is corruption in venezuela or human
rights abuses
but there is corruption and humanity
abuses in every single country the
question is what is the role of the us
that's outside power
which has no business doing anything in
venezuela
without the permission of its sovereign
government what is the role of the u.s
implementing all this and the role is
actually pretty strong it has funneled
tens of millions of dollars into the
venezuelan opposition
it tried a coup in 2002. uh under
starting under obama continuing under
trump and now continuing under biden
it's imposed murderous sanctions that
are aimed specifically
at starving the population so that
there is enough unrest to overthrow the
government to basically undermine
support for the government so
i i don't doubt for a second that there
is corruption in venezuela
people have been treated unfairly but
that to me is a venezuelan issue that's
for venezuelans to work out for
themselves
if i see my government terrorizing
venezuela
by literally trying to orchestrating a
coup this coup
involving wang guido would not have
happened if not for
dedicated u.s planning and support
there's just no way
there's even documents that have come
out showing how much how how
instrumental the u.s has been
in funding guido's operation
so that's what i'm concerned about i'm
concerned with what
my country is doing to another country
where it has no business doing anything
at all except leaving it alone
aaron actually you know obviously
there's areas of agreement there is
disagreement but on the principle i
agree with you i don't think
the united states should be going around
the world throwing its weight around
my suppose the counter argument i'm
trying to explore with you in my head is
what should the united states do if
anything about something like
the chinese communist party china and
let's say the uyghurs
should we just go well that's an
internal chinese problem let them get on
with putting people in concentration
camps
well first of all the question presumes
is if we have some kind of moral
authority
right we have some uh right
to act against another government now
notice how the question is never asked
what should the chinese communist party
do
against the u.s which is supporting a
genocide
in yemen without u.s support the
saudi-led genocide gamble would not be
happening
so the u.s is supporting genocide in
yemen it supported a dirty war in syria
that
i'm sorry to interrupt hold on those
things aren't fair equivalence because
that isn't
happening in the united states if the if
if the united states was imprisoning
i don't know latinos on mass and putting
them in camps and re-educating them then
that would be a fair comparison
uh do you see what i'm saying the u.s
actually has the highest incarceration
rate in the world and the u.s
doesn't doesn't actually give health
care to its own people so there's
there's even things internally the us is
doing to its own people which i think
uh under the standards
under these standards established by the
u.s would actually would actually
legitimate foreign intervention
but i don't uh i don't accept the
principle foreign intervention i first
of all i start with the premise that
everybody is equal
the u.s is not some enlightened
higher society that's a nazi way of
thinking i don't accept that we're not
better than china or anybody else we're
exactly the same
and in some ways we're actually a lot
more backward
and that we we have a foreign military
military occupations going on around the
world
and bases around the world and sanctions
around the world that nobody else is
doing
so i don't accept the premise that we
have some duty or some right
to act that we don't grant to other
other states
but isn't that the argument that would
say we had no reason
the united states shouldn't have
intervened in world war ii for example
well that's different because that's
when you have a nazi
army that is invading foreign states
and overseeing extermination and other
states that are being attacked by the
nazis have asked the u.s
to come to their defense so the the u.s
was asked for help
but that's different than say vietnam
where you know no nobody asked the u.s
to come into vietnam
no sovereign government said please come
in to vietnam or
you know the nicaragua the no no
sovereign nicaraguan said please come in
and destroy our country and uh the same
and you can repeat that everywhere
yemenis didn't say please give saudi
arabia
please arm saudi arabia and give them
intelligence so you can bomb our
countries bomb our weddings bomb our
water plants
so world war ii is a unique case i think
and
the only you know if the u.s did
anything wrong there that it came in way
too late it let the nazis
actually take far too much territory and
cause far too much death before it
finally came in
and look and by the way on the issue of
the uyghurs um
that's worth addressing because you know
it's interesting
we've only seen rhetoric around the
uyghurs come up in recent years
when meanwhile the conflict there has
been going on for a long time
there is undoubtedly repression in
xinjiang
i think that's that that's undoubtable
and there's a massive surveillance state
inside of china but we've only seen talk
about a genocide happen
in recent years and i think it's
important to look at
why in recent years china has become
more of a target
of the bipartisan u.s establishment
because it's a rising economic power
its economic success threatens
u.s hegemony and that's why i think
china is now in the u.s crosshairs and
that's why i think
we're hearing more accusations against
china of genocide
which by the way is a very strong term
which i do not use
uh when it comes to to uh to the uyghurs
genocide means mass extermination
there is repression there i think that's
uh and i haven't been there but i would
bet strongly that all the
allegations of oppression are true but
genocide means mass extermination
and anybody who wants to argue that
uh uyghurs in china are treated worse
than say palestinians in gaza
who are being occupied with u.s support
is is wrong it's just a falsehood so
there's
i think a very familiar playbook of
weaponizing
humanitarian rhetoric to actually
justify
the real aims of basically demonizing
china and waging a cold war against it
which i do not support
and do not worry what will happen aaron
if
as as you wish and correct me if i'm
wrong
that the us retreats from the world
stage that it just focuses
on its own problems and healthcare
whatever it is
what will happen to the world stage if
someone if countries like china and
russia
are allowed free reign that to me is
like asking
what you know in star wars if the death
star
was dismantled what would that mean for
the world the us
is a global empire show me another
country that has
bases in hundreds of countries around
the world that is waging simultaneous
military occupations
that is imposing uh a sanctioned regime
that cuts off massive countries
from the west of the world and denies
their civilians food and medicine that's
the case
in every single major target of u.s
regime change there's just no parallel
all these governments are corrupt they
repress their own people uh
and i'm not a fan of of pretty much any
government i i i you know but
i don't believe that this system of this
one global hegemon
that is constantly invading other
countries destroying other countries
blockading other countries uh is better
than a system where
there's not this one empire i think that
would be a wonderful thing
if there was not this one hegemon
controlling everything because it would
it would mean that we have no more
or at least able to reduce the chances
of this one bully
invading and blockading every country
that it doesn't like
do you think that's really true though
aaron i mean the the system with no
one power is is inherently unstable i
would argue and what you'd probably end
up with is
russia or china becoming that superpower
instead and would that be a better world
uh for russia and china to become a
superpower on the level of the us
that would require them building up
bases
around the world invading other
countries i don't see that happening
and when you talk about being less
stable well what is stable about the
current situation
where you have countries like iran
venezuela cuba syria you can go down the
list
starving under u.s sanctions and you
have this
a u.s government that you know pretty
much with every administration
invade somebody else you know look at
the last 20 years
the us invaded iraq destroyed iraq look
at the impact of iraq what that's done
not just to iraq
but to the whole region um isis
then goes into syria takes over a large
part of syria
look at afghanistan the invasion of
afghanistan back then al-qaeda was
concentrated to a very small part of
afghanistan
and neighboring pakistan look where they
are now now they're around the world
they're everywhere
they're in syria they're in somalia
they're in yemen that's a result
of u.s policy of the invasion of
afghanistan and also of iraq
then look at libya the destruction of
libya
slavery returning there the dirty war in
syria hundreds of thousands of people
killed millions displaced a country
destroyed now it can't even rebuild
because of u.s sanctions
iran people you know there was just
an article that came out in foreign
affairs talking about how millions of
iranians
have been plunged from the middle class
to below the poverty line because of u.s
sanctions
you can look everywhere around the world
so what is stable about that for
these millions tens of millions of
people there's nothing stable about
living under
you know the threat of war the impact of
the u.s
invading and now being surrounded by
extremist militias like
isis and living under medieval sanctions
that prevent them from importing their
basic goods like food and medicine well
on
afghanistan iraq and all that stuff we
we're completely with you and libya
uh and to a large extent syria i mean
some of the points you're making are
hard to disagree with no matter how
much i'd like to uh but aaron i i was
going to ask you
something a topic that we cover on on
this show
quite a bit is you know francis is a
very much old-school lefty i am some i
used to be on the left i'm very much
sort of in the center now i think
uh but one of the things we talk about a
lot and maybe it's our background as
comedians who are concerned about
increasing restrictions around speech
people being you know
cancelled for the wrong comment or
whatever that sort of thing
which does happen quite a lot uh in our
experience
as someone who's on the left and cares
about foreign policy cares about
economics
what do you make of what they what they
sort of call woke stuff or woke
culture work politics how do you feel
that's
useful or is it a distraction from the
main issues that left should focus on
what do you make of it
to the extent woke refers to
how i see its original intention
which is just to expand consciousness
about the world
be conscious of subconscious biases that
we
inherent as a result of living in a
unequal
racist system i think that is good you
know and i i'm on board with it
of course like everything it gets it's
been exploited to
distract us from the important issues
like the ones i've been talking about
and to sort of silo politics into this
very narrow thing where it's no longer
about
improving people's material well-being
meeting their basic needs
opposing things like imperialism and war
but instead very much focused solely on
solely on identity at the exclusion of
everything else there's nothing wrong
i think with recognizing the role of
identity
in our biases and trying to correct that
but when you do that
at the expense and in fact in opposition
to everything else
i think it's a very real problem and the
attempts to cancel people for saying the
wrong things is i think a part of this
where it's this like
effort to push us further and further
away from focusing on the things that
matter that impact people's lives
and instead on these semantic
narrow concerns that i just don't really
resonate with the vast majority of
people and that's certainly
an issue on the left that i think is
worrying that
you know i'm all for focusing on
identity issues and
uh you know uh for calling people by the
right pronouns i i think
we have to respect however someone wants
to be you know
uh described we have to respect it but
the problem is when people try to make
these things the sole issue uh at the
exclusion and in opposition
everything else that's a problem and you
see that especially now
with the democratic party leadership the
dnc they love this talk
because instead of talking about you
know the working class the minimum wage
uh or the impact of sanctioning and
bombing foreign countries
they can brag about how how diverse the
cabinet of officials
is that is carrying out these same awful
policies so sometimes this becomes
a smoke screen to continue the very same
policies the very same racist policies
of old so that's that's where i stand on
that and i'm certainly not comfortable
with
the incredible amount of suppression of
free speech
that's that's gone on recently and you
know we saw that here in the u.s before
the
election where there was this article in
the new york post about joe biden and
his son hunter and his
uh hunters corrupt business dealings
abroad and literally
when you wanted to share that on twitter
you couldn't twitter blocked
people from sharing that and that is a
manifestation of this increased policing
and censorship of speech
and it's you know uh in the case of this
hunter biden story
one way in which they justified it is
they said that this might be russian
disinformation and that's another
way all this has happened is that
anything that offends us elites
gets labeled russian disinformation and
that way we can bury it so you know
all this ethic is is concerning
hey constantine do you like success well
i'm working with you
so clearly not there's this great new
podcast called secret leaders where they
have honest conversations
with fascinating people from the world
of business have they taken our strap
line because if they have i'm gonna sue
the [ __ ] [ __ ] back
no no no i wrote that bit ah
okay well tell me about secret leaders
then it's
brilliant they interview some of the
most successful entrepreneurs
in the world my personal favorite was
with huel
founder julian hearn who explains how to
become a food and drink
millionaire yeah you listen to that one
because it's all about food didn't you
yeah i knew it who else have they
interviewed then i don't know only
listen to the food once
joking aside though they've talked to
the founders of pioneering startups like
brewdog monzo and joe malone
my favorite episode actually was with
alex stephanie
the ceo of beam who spoke about how
business could solve huge societal
problems
like homelessness oh wow that sounds
great where do i go to listen to secret
leaders
just download it right now from wherever
you get your podcast
all you need to do is search for secret
leaders easy
and aaron don't you see that when it
comes
to leftist parties this identitarian
politics
is slowly tearing it apart because it's
making them
less and less electable and less and
less relevant to working class people
who they're meant to be serving i think
there is truth to that yes
i do i do i do now i
that doesn't mean that i think leftists
shouldn't talk about identity and
prioritize addressing racism
and any other form of discrimination but
when it's done at the exclusion of
everything else and again in opposition
to improving people's material interests
that's when i think it's a problem
and unfortunately i think that trend of
solely focusing on identity while still
advancing policies that in fact hurt
people of color
hurt marginalized communities like you
know for example not
being able to fight for a 15 minimum
wage as the democratic party just
just showed us i think i think that is a
real problem and it will cost
the democrats and other liberals around
the world votes
because when things are rough you know
uh when there's no economic alternative
and there's no
party offering you any hope and any sort
of means to
improve your your economic condition it
becomes much easier to scapegoat
other people so whether it's people of
color or
immigrants those things become a lot
people become a lot more susceptible to
demagogues like trump
blaming immigrants for their problems
instead of being willing to look at
usa elites u.s corporations that are
causing the problems
and democrats that refuse to call out
those corporations
and instead try to pretend that they're
awoke simply because they have
you know a diverse group of people in
their cabinet or they use the right
pronouns
it's not going to work right and the
thing as well is if you target
your efforts at working-class people you
will inevitably disproportionately help
people who are from ethnic from other
minorities because they tend to be
over-represented in that
group anyway aaron i'm just uh wary that
we have to let you go because you've got
another thing to to run to
so i just want to say uh thank you very
much for appearing on the show
uh it's been a pleasure chatting with
you we had a nice bit of back and forth
and we've got one more question for you
which is always what's the one thing
we're not talking about
but we really should be well
politically to me i think
the dirty war on syria has not gotten
nearly enough attention and the way it's
been described in the western media
especially in the british media and the
us media is a scandal
the us and its allies spent billions of
dollars
on a dirty war in syria which in the
words of joe biden
ultimately benefited al-qaeda and isis
he blurted this out
in a comment in 2014 which he later had
to apologize for but he was he was
telling the truth
and the picture we got in the western
media was
just not accurate as to what was
actually going on we really helped
destroy the country and now
syrians cannot rebuild their country
because the us is overseeing what's
called the caesar sanctions which
explicitly targets syria's
reconstruction the us
openly brags that it's destroying
syria's economy through these sanctions
and preventing it from rebuilding
and meanwhile this is in parallel with
the us occupying still militarily a
third of syria
which also does not get get very much
attention so i think the us efforts to
destroy syria along with its allies
including the uk should get far more
attention and
at minimum we should be lifting these
murderous sanctions that are preventing
a country that we help destroy
from rebuilding i hope people give that
much more attention
along with a scandal that i've been
covering very closely
at the gray zone and the nation magazine
which is that as a part of this dirty
war
uh to impose sanctions on syria
and to justify foreign aggression
against it syria has been accused of
carrying out these chemical weapons
attacks
and you can go through every incident
and there's
sketchy evidence in all the big cases
but the most
glaring one is the case of douma in 2018
april 2018 where syria was accused of
chemical weapons attack
the us britain and france bombed syria
but then
there's been this scandal in the opcw
the organization for the prohibition of
chemical weapons which actually went to
duma to syria to investigate this
and a whole series of leaks show that
internally the inspectors who went to
douma
did not find evidence of a chemical
weapons attack but their evidence was
suppressed
their initial report was doctored and
the opcw
put out a report that was completely
misleading
and contradicted what its own inspectors
had found
and this this coincided with the us
effort to pressure the opcw
to come to a conclusion that happened to
match the u.s narrative that syria was
guilty
of a chlorine attack so that is a global
scandal where basically
similar to what we saw before the iraq
war
the us is compromising the opcw to
basically
doctor claims that justify u.s war
mongering
that justify a bombing of syria and now
justify sanctions
and there are whistleblowers inside the
opcw who have challenged this
who deserve our support and certainly
our attention because
try to find a reference to this in the
us or uk media
and it's very very hard to find a few
people have covered it
peter hitchens of the daily mail has
covered it i've covered it at the gray
zone jonathan steele the veteran british
correspondent has covered it
but aside from that it does not get very
much get very much attention and there
was finally there was just a new
development where
there was an open letter just published
it's available at the courage foundation
uh courage found.org and it's a
statement
by a whole bunch of signatories
including noam chomsky
daniel ellsberg lawrence wilkerson who
served as
the chief of staff to colin powell tulsi
gabbard
as well as five former opcw officials
voicing support for the whistleblowers
and
urging the opcw to stop silencing them
and to let them air the suppressed
scientific findings
uh from their own investigation so i
hope people pay attention to that story
and if they're interested there's a lot
more they can find about it at
thegrayzone.com
fantastic aaron thank you so much for
coming on the show it's
we absolutely loved it uh if people want
to find you where is the best place to
do that
thegrayzone.com thegrayzone.com thank
you very much you already told you mate
come on pay attention
well yeah you can get in a second time
aaron listen it's been a great uh it's a
really valuable perspective to add
uh your as i said at the beginning
you're a voice it's very different
there'll be plenty of things for people
to agree and disagree on but that's what
we love and
you know it's great for us who who
really love speaking to people who are
on the left because that's kind of where
we've come from
it's so increasingly rare now to get
people on who actually believe in having
conversations and disagreeing and
and free speech so you know all props to
you for coming on the show we really
appreciate it all the best
and we encourage everyone to check out
your work particularly uh the story you
mentioned about syria
thank you everyone for watching we'll
see you at 7 p.m with another interview
all live stream uh take care and they
always go out 7 p.m uk time i just said
that again well done it doesn't matter
this is the level of professionalism you
get on the show this is what happens
when you involve comedians in anything
all right thanks we hope you've enjoyed
this
incredible interview remember to
subscribe and hit the bell button
so that you never miss another fantastic
episode
and if you believe that the work we do
here at trigonometry is important
support us by joining our locals
community using the link below